[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily
we're taking a closer look now at one of
the key players in the johnny depp v
amber heard trial who has recently taken
the internet by storm law and crime
networks here at gillespie joins us now
to explain who camille vasquez is and
what her relationship is with client
johnny depp
the world was introduced to camille
vasquez during her opening statement for
depp and the truth will come out in this
trial but vasquez really made her mark
with the cross-examination of amber hurd
this was a a multi-day assault that took
place over three horrible days worst
thing ever
we're not misheard that's not my
question entertainment attorney mitra
ahurian says vasquez asked the right
questions in the right way i think she
really stepped up during
cross-examination of amber heard
and
everything we saw about her was good
lawyering
she came in with the right attitude the
right confidence and really had what we
call good control of the witness and
that's key when you're trying to get
your narrative across is making sure
that you're controlling the testimony of
the witness so that they're not veering
off into the version of the story that
they want to tell lawn crime legal
analyst dina dahl agrees saying vasquez
was a standout on cross camille vasquez
did an excellent job on her
cross-examination i mean that's a really
hard cross-examination to do you're
cross-examining somebody who's alleging
domestic violence it's a very serious
allegation and but yet she has to ask
these really tough questions to be an
advocate for her lawyer that's a very
fine line and i thought
she was perfect i can't see anybody
having done it better she was firm she
was really great with the type of
questions just the style of her
questioning
i thought that
she was so effective that i don't know
how amber heard quite frankly come back
from the cross that she did experts say
the female direction in this case is
likely a strategic move
it's probably not a coincidence that
they had the two females cross-examine
the two females i think they just don't
like that image of a man cross-examining
a woman on these very sensitive topics
of domestic violence and what about that
noticeable friendship between depp and
vasquez we can't ignore the beautiful
chemistry her and johnny have
together in the courtroom that's really
lovely to watch but is the relationship
something more i don't think they
necessarily have a relationship i have a
lot of clients that i've represented for
a really long time
that i'm
very affectionate towards and i care
about and when they're going through an
emotional
time
part of what you are as one of my
clients calls me consigliati like part
of it is your counselor lawn crime
network has reached out to camille
vasquez for a comment but hasn't heard
back yet she and attorney benjamin chu
are expected to present closing
arguments for depp this friday reporting
for long crime network i'm sierra
gillespie
thanks sierra dina you touched on this a
bit in the story but let's dig a little
deeper how do female attorneys play such
a large role in this trial and why is
that so important
you know it may be this outdated
stereotype but they certainly you know
lawyers are certainly aware of how they
are going to be perceived by the jury
and so they don't want to appear as if
they are you know attacking a female
victim who is you know alleging
something that's really disturbing and
so they will often use a female tourney
to do that questioning in a way to maybe
try to
not make it look like there's this man
attacking this woman again whether or
not this is this outdated sexist notion
it does happen for strategic reasons i
do not think it is outdated at all i
would never personally as a 6'4 200 plus
black man come hard and cross-examine
amber heard definitely uh dina or terry
do it terry
i don't think it will happen based on
seniority and the fact that she did the
opening statement but if you had the
choice would you put camille vasquez in
place of doing the closing arguments
well absolutely and i think what they
are going to do is split it like they
did with the opening i do think that
when camille did part of that opening
she wasn't as strong she did get her
legs when she did that cross-examination
and actually i think all three of the
attorneys for depp are excellent i think
ben chu has a role there i think wayne
dennison even though he is not as strong
in my opinion i think all three of them
have had their part in making this so
far successful the star the breakout
star no doubt about it is camille and i
think she will have a stronger voice
when she does this closing and i think
she will help them pull it all together
so if i were them i would have her do
the closing and maybe you know at the
end of the day
be the last voice that anyone can hear
at this trial as far as depth's team is
concerned all right so dina likes her
terry likes her i likes her but the
major question is does the jury will
find out as we continue thank you for
joining us here on law and crime daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america